investisseurs mécène qu'on connaît bien
mon sommes sur la sonde faire plaisir
mais ça nous fait plaisir d'entendre
votre perspective commençons par la
hausse du prix de l'argent
selon vous est-ce que c'est fondamental
ou est-ce que c'est spéculatifs écoutez
je pense que en grande partie
aujourd'hui de toute façon c'est surtout
spéculatifs mais faut pas oublier que
nous sommes dans un marché à la hausse
autant pour l'or que pour l'argent alors
l'argent qui est d'ailleurs une si vous
voulez le cas passer de 15 à 25 dollars
dans les deux dernières années donc
c'est déjà un marché à la hausse
mais aujourd'hui clairement spéculatifs
clairement spéculatifs aujourd'hui donc
est ce que vous le liés à ces fameuses
investisseurs de red dead qui ont
provoqué beaucoup de spéculations
boursières sur d'autres sites au cours
des dernières semaines
oui tout à fait genre tout à fait en
fait si vous allez sur le 7e résister
puis si vous lisez les différents trucs
sur facebook et où il ya une jonquille
et on parle d'une conspiration où il ya
des chocs dans le marché de l'argent et
on veut faire la même chose qu'on a fait
pour game seul gamestop alors mais ici
c'est complètement différent
par contre si vous vous souvenez dans
les années audi où tu libye les années
80 les frères exauce avait fait
exactement la même chose avec le marché
de l'argent qu'ils avaient été passés de
5 $ à 52 dollars en 1980 alors c'est ça
c'est déjà presque pas du nouveau la
salle déjà été fait mais aujourd'hui le
marché il est beaucoup plus liquide
qu'il était à ce moment alors si vous
regardez il ya l'an passé à 27 milles
tonnes d'argent qui a été produit saisir
864 millions d'onces pratiquement 1
milliard dans ce qui est produit par
année c'est un marché qui est très
liquide est très profond et jeu
crois que ça va être extrêmement
difficile aux spéculateurs de faire
monter si vous voulez d'argent des
valeurs comme on le fait dans les années
80 parce que ça peut avoir un impact
important sur sur le reste de la chaîne
puisque l'argent se retrouve dans
plusieurs industries plusieurs matériaux
oui tout à fait et l'impact qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui aussi on l'a vu sur les
titres boursiers et l panaméricaine
sauveur et l inde et l ue à ségou
danseurs qui sont à la hausse à peu près
de 10% chaque et avec une hausse du prix
de l'argent de cinq grands oubliez pas
que ce signe de leur parlons par ans il
se retrouve directement dans la ligne
des profits ou voilà alors il ya un
effet levier qui est très très important
pour les titres les titres argentifère
est-ce que vous pensez que la poussée
actuelle peut se déplacer sur d'autres
métaux le sud je dirais que le seul
autre métal où on pourrait voir ce genre
de spéculation c'est dans l'or parce que
dans les marchés comme le cuivre ils
sont pas que ce ne sont pas des marchés
qui sont vraiment facile à pénétrer et
ce sont des marchés qui sont dirigés en
90 % par les grandes entreprises
authentique ou des ventes que du côté à
chaud très douce est la seule autre robe
marché qui est vraiment libre et de
course et le marché de là où vous pouvez
acheter par exemple le tf sur la bourse
et mais encore c'est un marché très
profond quand on parle de la vente à
découvert
on attaque en quelque sorte les jeunes
investisseurs qui ont pu le faire à
partir de la plateforme
benoît de puydt les discussions sur le
web et s'en prennent à ces fonds
spéculatifs qui parient à la baisse sur
sur des titres avec cet outil et
financier qui s'appelle qui s'appelle la
vente à découvert est ce qu a beaucoup
de ça dans le monde des métaux comme
l'argent comme l'or écoutez si beau si
vous regardez sur certains sites que
vous allez voir qu'il ya toutes sortes
de consulter de lorient 2-2
théories de complot le complot mais
c'est absolument incroyable
alors on se dit que oui il ya eu des
ventes à découvert de centaines de
millions d'onces d'argent et puis si
vous aussi vous empilez là dedans vous
allez capable d'aller squeezé vous avez
vont tous sortir mais comme je dis très
bien quand on parle de près de 1
milliard de dons d'argent qui est
produit à chaque année ça ne sera pas la
même le même jeu du tout du tout que
gamestop qui était un marché où il ya un
nombre limité d'action et non seulement
ça mais les simples 20% des actions
avait été vendue à découvert alors ça
c'est un une situation qui se portait si
vous voulez à la manipulation mais le
marché de l'argent et le marché de l'or
beaucoup moins est ce que ça vous
inquiète en terminant sur la sambre vous
êtes un investisseur connus reconnus
est ce que ça vous inquiète ce qui se
passe présentement dans le marché cette
espèce de frénésie spéculative papa du
côté métal parce que je pense que viva
ils vont peut-être avoir ni une hausse
de 5,5 10 15 ou 20 % monsieur qui achète
ne perdront pas tout leur argent parce
que une valeur fondamentale et surtout
ce sont des marchés qui sont à la hausse
mais par contre lorsqu'on parle des
marchés boursiers en général comme
gamestop et d'autre mais là évidemment
ces titres là est la fin du jour ils ont
une valeur intrinsèque fondamentale game
stocks et des stops étaient 5 dollars
auparavant
alors quand ça monte à 130 dollars vous
avez une plus value de 125 qui n'existe
pas alors les personnes qui achètent les
deux sites à ces prix-là sens où 200 300
dollars mais il risque de perdre 99% de
la voir alors oui il vraiment un danger
qui guette existants et mais vous savez
c'est la démocratisation des marchés
c'est comme ça qu'on voit ça est-ce
qu'on devrait arrêter tout ça est ce que
les autorités financières sont en
arrière lui aucun doute là dessus
est-ce que des manipulations c'est sûr
il ya des gros requins blancs qui sont à
la vente tout ça et puis une grosse
école de poissons derrière eux puis
c'est eux qui mènent le bal et eux ils
font les dizaines des centaines de
millions mais par contre les petits
poissons à l'arrière de l'école de
poisson bleu ils vont se faire manger
alors prudence c'est le message grande
prudence effective
merci monsieur la sonde merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir un grand
plaisir comme toujours